happy deathday was one of the surprise
cinematic successes of 2017 earning a
nice mint at the box office and
entertaining audiences with its
Groundhog Day Meets scream plot line on
the surface the story is simple college
girl is forced to relive the same day
over and over until she finds out who's
killing her but while the movie provides
a fun mix of the genre humor and jump
scares happy deathday also explores some
deeper issues in character development
here's a look at what the ending to the
film really meant for a birthday girl
Mean Girl redemption in the beginning of
the story tree is depicted as the
stereotypical sorority girl basically
some snivelling version of regina george
and chanel from scream queens she's mean
and materialistic and doesn't seem to
care about anyone but herself
but while audiences are immediately
inclined to hate tree her backstory
starts to trickle in and offer some
sympathetic elements along the way as
the story moves forward she becomes
almost like Abel and as the stabs roll
in they start to sting more and more
screen writer Scott Lobdell told
Thrillist that he intended to subvert
the traditional heroine trope with tree
saying every slasher film opens up with
the main girl getting killed and the
good girl living till the end and I
thought how can I make the mean girl and
the good girl the same person there have
been a lot of final girls to hit the
scream queen same but never quite like
this
a guardian angel one thing the film does
not explain is the scientific was
supernatural reason for trees time-loop
director Christopher Landon has said
that he meant for it to be a big mystery
but that hasn't stopped fans from
guessing what started at all one popular
theory is that her deceased mother is
orchestrating the whole thing from
beyond the grave to forestry to finally
deal with her grief and reconcile with
her father after all she continually
leaves a bracelet her mother gave her
behind and seems to love the night life
sibility to drown out her sorrows and
she seems especially uninterested in
celebrating a birthday which she just so
happens to share with a late mum as she
comes face-to-face with their mortality
though she starts to reflect on memories
of her mum and eventually realizes that
she needs to help repair her fractured
family dynamic with her dad my mom's
hanging out you who had become I don't
think she'd be very proud the guardian
angel concept might seem silly but how
else do you explain a woman living the
same bitter end again and again like
this a red herring
since trace personal Grim Reaper is
always concealed by a baby mask we don't
know for sure who's responsible for her
many ends throughout the movie so once
we learned that a known serial Slayer
named Joseph tooms has been hospitalized
nearby he seems like just as good a
suspect as any tree decides to get ahead
of the attack and stop terms in his
tracks but it takes a couple of tries to
get it right and even when she does
manage to get the upper hand on the vile
villain there's a catch since her
budding beau cotta has tried to save her
and gets lost in the process tree knows
that if she breaks the time loop she'll
sacrifice a new fella as much as she
might want out of the vicious cycle she
still decides to offer self and try
again instead the scene showcases trees
sudden sense of selflessness and puts
off the inevitable revelation that terms
isn't who she's really after anyway
superficial killer superficial world as
we learn in the film's final moments
trees attacker has been right under her
nose the entire time instead of an
escaped convict or some stalker ex it's
a jealous roommate lorry who arrives as
the culprit from the very beginning
lorry offers treat a birthday cupcake as
a gift and each time our hero declines
to eat it she finally takes a
celebratory bite when she believes she's
vanquished have villain by taking out
Geoffrey terms and what do you know she
wakes up again to the same thing tree
then realizes that the cupcake caused a
demise and has one final fight with
Laurie in the fracas it's revealed that
her roommate started her slaughter spree
because of jealousy over a boy tree
manages to kick her roommate to the curb
in a very literal sense and finally
manages to make it to tomorrow despite
one cruel morning prank pulled off by
Carter but more importantly her true
moment of salvation stems from the fact
that she's also laid waste to some very
bad habits and can start this new leg of
a life on the right foot thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]